etwas getappt und herzlich willkommen
zum video ich hoffe natürlich euch geht
es gut ich habe vor einiger zeit ja mal
influenza produkte getestet das ist
jetzt schon circa so im jahr her ich
glaube ich sogar zwei teile von gemacht
und ich dachte mir damit kann man auf
jeden fall mal weitermachen allerdings
mit einer etwas anderen variante und
zwar ist es ja nach wie vor so dass
insgesamt liegt ob youtube alles ist
voll mit irgendwelchen produkten die
neue rauskommen und dann extrem von
influence angeworben werden hat er jetzt
wirklich so in letzter zeit wieder
einige beispiele wo ich mir dachte okay
das wirkt so auf den ersten blick zwar
ganz cool aber ist es halt auch
irgendwie sehr teuer und ich dachte mir
wir testen mal ein paar weitere
influenza produkte und vergleichen die
dann mit günstigeren alternativen also
den meisten produkten gibt es ja dann
irgendwie schon ein anderes produkt was
es halt ganz normal zu kaufen gibt und
was weniger als die hälfte kostet
deswegen würde ich sagen aber gar nicht
lange viele sachen sind dabei und wir
starten mit dem ersten produkt und das
ist wo ich wünsche euch viel spaß bei
diesem video und ab und jetzt sehr sehr
gerne meinen youtube-kanal let's go so
leute wir starten mit dem ersten
influenza produkt und zwar ist das water
drop das ganze war sogar eine höhle der
löwen produkt und wird intensiv von
verschiedensten influence in beworben an
sich sind das einfach tabletten die kann
man ins wasser tun dann schmeckt das
wasser nach irgendetwas und die verben
auf jeden fall damit dass es ein
zuckerfreier micro drink ist so sieht
auf jeden fall deren website aus und ich
habe hier einfach mal so ein starterset
bestellt wobei als ich bestellt hat gab
es andere starter sets da waren diese
fleisch noch nicht was halt nur hier
diese tabletten oder mikro drinks wie
das nennen bekommen das ist auch jetzt
schon ein weilchen her die lieferzeit
war auf jeden fall länger als die
versprochen haben also ich habe ein
bisschen darauf gewartet aber wir
schauen uns das jetzt mal an und schauen
dann auf das knallt und also nur was ich
mir wirklich als erstes so gedacht habe
wir haben hier irgendwelche geschmacks
tabletten für wasser dann schmeckt ein
wasser nach irgendwas und die kosten
halt bei rossmann zum beispiel so eine
packung selbst eur 990 bin ich schon
echt teuer ich habe jetzt hier folgendes
bestellt ein mal das mikro drink
probierpaket für 14 99 wir glaube ich
alle sachen einmal drin sind also alle
verschiedenen geschmacksrichtungen und
ja das hier ist angekommen machen wir
mal
relaxen
august just und focus die viele sind
jetzt in einer drei kapseln hier können
wir sieht aus wie sie ihr also browser
halten dann möchte ich gerne auch relax
probieren boost boost boost also das ist
das erste produkt wir testen das erst
mal und danach gastieren die günstigen
alternativen ja wann mal hierhin ich
fange einfach mal mit relax on water
drop ist das zuckerfreie würfelchen dass
dein wasser mit ausgesuchten frucht und
pflanzenextrakte sowie wertvollen
vitaminen angereichert damit ist es noch
leichter täglich genug wasser zu trinken
kostet zwar auch nur sagen ich
bin jetzt mal gespannt und vielleicht
ist das ja ist auch das leckerste was
ich hier getrunken habe wenn wir schon
mal dabei sind werde ich direkt mal
weiter an richtern
und zwar habe ich mir noch folgendes wir
haben als alternative ich muss sagen
also ich würde mir das jetzt auch nicht
zwingend kaufen das ist auch teuer
54 also das ist aber so was ähnliches
ist außerdem geschmacks pulver was man
ja jetzt rein coppola lacroix
ich habe keine ahnung wieso so viel
höhere 50 kostüme oder wir machen es
einfach ganz günstig für 30 cent was ich
früher wie ich hin und wieder mal
genommen habe einfach hier so vitamin c
genauso wie das andere zeug damit ein
bisschen geschmack es ist glaube ich
fertig wäre relaxt jetzt mal ein
bisschen
muss ich dann schmeckt mir gut wird es
mal probiert weil es echt lecker koste
heute auf 692 das hat wirklich glaubt
dass dinge diese pole kostet 49 cent
oder so war dann war auch mal rein jetzt
haben wir hier die auch schon sehr teure
alternative finde ich das ist jetzt hier
40 geschmack noch vier sich orangenblüte
schmeckt mir nicht gut ich muss auch
sagen ich checke nicht mehr kaufen da
ist also ich würde ja verstehen ich habe
mir zum beispiel sehr lange wasser
gemacht und hat man einfach so ein
bisschen sirup unten rein gemacht und
dann wasser aufgefüllt super lecker da
kannst du ja mit auskommen mit einem
sonder zero flasche und die kostet ja
aber das ist ja zucker drin
wahrscheinlich das sind ja alles für
zuckerfreie alternativen wobei
vielleicht das hier zucker drin dann ist
mir auch egal in speyer sechs euro da
trinke ich ein bisschen sogar für das
schmeckt schon sehr intensiv danach süß
und allem ich muss sagen fazit ich fand
auf jeden fall den water drop bringt am
leckersten von allen aber ich finde es
halt einfach zu teuer
da und deswegen wäre das jetzt kein
produkt was ich supporten würde möchtest
du noch hier was anderes probieren
gleichfalls dieser geschmack uns um haut
dann melde ich mich auf jeden fall
nochmal wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt und das ist jim tastic
und es lustig ist die kosten 150 euro
aber mit den verschiedenen -influenza
codes gibt es bis zu 60 prozent rabatt
und die hatten sogar dauerhaften code
auf der website mit dem es auch zu der
zeit als ich gekauft habe 50 prozent
rabatt gab für mich klingt das sind
immer noch ein bisschen zu viel rabatt
aber so eine jim kann hier für 150 euro
ist auch schon ansage ich muss dazu noch
ganz gut was erzählen und zwar habe ich
vor zwei wochen bestellt ungefähr das
dingen ist leider immer noch nicht da es
kommt aber morgen an ich habe nämlich
noch die gym dann 1 bestellt und dann
bekam ich irgendwann eine nachricht ja
dass jetzt die zweite rauskommt und die
mir direkt die zweite schicken ich noch
ein bisschen warten muss und dann hab
ich gewartet und gewartet und gewartet
dann habe ich irgendwann bei instagram
gefragt ja was ist denn jetzt mit meiner
ganz meiden sie auch die es jetzt heute
dann auch unterwegs das war ein bisschen
schade dass dingen kommt auf jeden fall
mit verschiedenen massage aufsetzen und
auch ganz vielen verschiedenen gängen
also so ja bald massage gängen bis zu 40
prozent tiefer als andere geräte
also man muss sagen aktuell kommen um
jim tastic nicht rum die dem testat gern
ich kann nicht anders als ständig von
diesem produkt zu schwärmen so johanna
weiß was du doch jetzt mal hier die gibt
es tricks auspacken und mir dann mal
verraten was war dein erster eindruck
dazu ist für die gymnastik massage dann
hab ich jetzt 76 eur 80 bezahlt wird
einem wundervollen gutscheincode von
diesem jungen herrn hierzu haben sich
über mein leben bislang über 600 leute
die massage angestellt und ja ich freue
mich auch jedes mal wenn die mit gibt
einfach phänomenal werbung würde ich
sagen und ich hab doch eine andere
massage kann bestellt die kostet im
internet nicht mal 30 euro die schauen
uns da ja auch noch an aber macht jetzt
erstmal auch ich bin nicht apa
und was sagst du meinst du damit kannst
du dich auch nicht weg massieren leute
ich habe ja schon gesagt ursprünglich
habe ich die dem testsieg 1 bestellt und
das ist jetzt die gestik 2 also die hat
noch mehr gänge und er kommt hier in
einer guten verpackung ich muss sagen
erster eindruck ist auf jeden fall nicht
verkehrt ich bin mal gespannt ob dieses
ding wirklich jetzt 76 euro wert ist
muss sagen das wird auf jeden fall
eigentlich ganz gut ziemlich schwer
mache ich mal einen wilden aufs tor auf
welchen nehmen achso hier ist das
ladegerät dabei was haben wir hier noch
beschreibung es riecht es nicht auf
jeden fall sehr nach plastik connect
besaß und ja die ganzen aufsätze glaube
dass das so der standard aufsatz ich
habe zum beispiel der schule auch
richtig gut und aufsätzen kommt mal
aufgeladen ist es schon und jetzt hast
du so was schon mal probiert und ich
mache jetzt einfach mal an wie man kann
das jetzt auch hier schneller machen wo
also an sich geht es ja bei den massagen
ganz darum so ein bisschen die muskeln
zu entspannen nach einem anstrengenden
workout oder einfach nur um sich ein
bisschen zu relaxen und ich muss sagen
das gefällt mir gerade ein ich soweit
echt gut manchmal noch mehr
30 gänge haben wir hier ja das fühlt
sich schon recht gut und machen wir mal
hier noch bei der wade ein bisschen ich
würde noch eben einen anderen aufsatz
verwenden hannover stoppte ok den
anderen fand ich jetzt deutlich besser
ich muss sagen mir gefällt hier an
dieser massage kann dass das ding 30
stufen hat es macht wirklich ich hätte
nicht gedacht weil ich habe das ding so
ähnlich auch auf alle express gesehen
für 13 euro deswegen dachte ich okay
schwierig aber man muss sagen es ist
wirklich viel viel hochwertiger als ich
mir vorgestellt aber ich habe ja noch
eine alternative bestellt und ich
schauen wir uns jetzt auch mal auf jeden
fall haben wir hier von der marke navi
tal die massage pistole ebenfalls mit
vier aufsetzen ja sechs
geschwindigkeitsstufen leichtes gewicht
akkubetrieb also eigentlich das gleiche
in grün nur mit weniger gängen und
deutlich günstiger also die na'vi
teilmassage kann liegt im internet circa
bei 22 bis 26 euro um vp eigentlich 39
runtergesetzt ja sagen wir einfach mal
dringen kostet 25 euro und wir schauen
uns das jetzt mal einfach mal auf hier
sagt man muss sagen was einem direkt
auffällt es ist deutlich kleiner
das ist der fall und ich denke da fehlt
auch dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
die power aber wir werden bei dem test
ickern haben wir zwei weitere aufsätze
die es für mich gibt wahrscheinlich ist
die lehrer müssen wir erst kurz aufladen
bis gleich also man muss ganz ehrlich
sagen hier liegen qualitativ schon
deutliche unterschiede vor gerade wenn
man sich die verschiedenen aufsätze
anschaut jeder schwarze von der gym
technikern ist auf jeden fall deutlich
hochwertiger produziert das ist so ein
bisschen hole das kann ja ich weiß auch
nicht also man merkt den unterschied
aber jetzt schicken wir mal aus wenn wir
beide gleichzeitig zum laufen bringen
welche sich dann besser anfühlt ich
probiere es einfach mal mache jetzt mal
ganz 20 und hergang 6
dabei kommt man im endeffekt erfüllen
jetzt gerade das ist jetzt hier der
höchste gang und jetzt mach ich mal hier
den höchsten lagen
da heißt auch nicht also im endeffekt
tut's die hier auch rechts also um es
kurz zu halten die macht auf jeden fall
deutlich hochwertigeren eindruck du hast
hier mehr aufsätze du hast sicherlich
auch eine längere akkulaufzeit wenn man
es auf lädt bis zu 30 gänge hier sind
halt nur sechs aber wenn man jetzt
einmal nur entspannt abends mal so ein
bisschen sich so passieren was man
möchte vor dem gerät zählt auch das für
25 euro ansonsten finde ich die hier für
75 euro akzeptabel also 150 euro sowie
die eigentlich kostet ohne influenza
gutscheincode will ich dafür nicht
bezahlen 75 finde ich in ordnung
deswegen hier einen daumen nach oben von
mir für das influenza a product key
weiter geht's jetzt wird es vielleicht
ein bisschen lächerlich aber ich wollte
es einfach mal ausprobiert und zwar
machen jetzt war damit eher leute der
ein oder andere wird sich hat sicherlich
fragen er ab das gibt's doch schon so
lange und das habe ich auch schon mal
getestet mein fazit damals war ja nicht
so krass positiv also ich dachte ich hab
mir halt diesen geruch viel intensiver
vorgestellt ich muss sagen dass ich
trotzdem erlaubt danach eine lange zeit
benutzt habe jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr
aber ich habe es benutzt und ich fand es
am ende auch eigentlich ganz gut hat mir
jetzt mal ein paar neue putz besorgt
dass in insgesamt drei stück die kosten
im rossmann fünf euro 99 meine ich nicht
schon sehr lecker ein portal für ca 5
liter steht so drauf würde ich auch
sagen dass das ungefähr hin kommt
mancher vielleicht nicht gar nichts dann
lässt der geschmack so irgendwann halt
nach und man wechselt in port vor den
fünf litern aber wir legen den jetzt mal
hier drauf dann ziehen wir den hoch
gerade für mich das wieder nicht so gut
mache ich irgendwas falsch
jetzt funktioniert also wenn man das
kontinuierlich macht dann ist es
irgendwann cool aber jetzt gerade ihm
fehlt wieder so ein bisschen dieser war
häufig sowie als ich beim ersten mal
probiert hatten hochziehen
ich weiß auch nicht so ganz ihr könnt ja
gerne meine kommentare schreiben benutzt
ihr das noch weil ich weiß und an meinem
video von damals haben viele geschrieben
dass sie begeisterte erb kunden sind
deswegen möchte ich jetzt hier auch
wieder nicht vermiesen aber ich dachte
mir wir testen jetzt mal was und zwar
habe ich mal eine kleinigkeit
vorbereitet und wichtig leute nehmen es
mit humor man muss ja sagen zu r ab gibt
es keine günstige alternative weil er ab
hat ein patent angemeldet finde ich auch
schlau hätte ich auch gemacht wenn ich
erb wäre aber ich bin halt alex ich habe
mir jetzt mal vier sicher gekauft die
auch schon nach vier sich riechen auch
sehr intensiv so weiter und ich werde
jetzt diesem 4 sich hier mal kurz einmal
durchschneiden ich hab noch nie sich
vorher meinem leben geschnitten zu
bieten hat auch super intensiven noch
vier sich die ganze 40 packungen ja die
jetzt 22 gekostet bei kaufland da kann
ich einige erbs mittrinken ihr denkt ich
wahrscheinlich gerade was ist los mit
hilton hat und jetzt will können wir das
hier schön ein vorsichtig
also leute günstige alternative es
riecht bricht schon sehr nach vier sich
guckt nicht mal schon einig also hast du
das gedacht
das war auch mein gedanke das kann doch
nicht so schwierig sein wenn du jetzt
nicht jede woche sechs euro ausgeben
kann es für so ein bisschen 40 tabs ist
das doch hier vielleicht die alex wii
variante gar nicht so schlecht kann auch
gern noch mal ein paar löcher rein
machen bei den potts ist es ja so dass
das dann auch so ein bisschen sprudelt
und dann sich der geschmack da irgendwie
so ein bisschen rein schleichen soll das
ist hier jetzt halt nicht möglich glaube
ich aber an sich riechst du das ja das
ist für sich ist würde ich jetzt
natürlich privat so nicht anwenden aber
es ist möglich und es halt günstig dafür
bittet man den daumen nach oben jetzt
alle hier das wollte ich so jetzt
einfach mal testen und wir machen jetzt
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt jetzt
geht es mal um die beauty damen wir
machen jetzt was für die mädels und zwar
haben wir hier die marke type college so
webseiten sind auch alle so gibt sind so
dass alles so groß wie machen in erster
linie hier so sehr um genau das hier
habe ich bestellt sehr um gezielt gegen
punktuelle unreinheiten genau das kostet
dann hier 24 euro oder sondern euro 50
ich würde sagen das hast du jetzt auch
mal und schauen ob pollack tolles per
politik kommt auf jeden fall aus
frankreich und sorgte so ziemlich für
halb die machen vegane und
tierversuchsfreie produkte das ist
zumindest manieren marketingkonzept mit
der aufhänger von dem ganzen influenza
alles recyclebar und so weiter und so
fort also wundert euch über diese
komischen aufnahmen ich hatte keine
besseren und ich schneide das video
gerade aus ich muss sagen in diesem
thema kann ich mich überhaupt nicht aus
so ich benutze ich produkte einfach
nicht deswegen bin ich froh dass johanna
heute unser test kaninchen ist und wir
haben hier halt einige sachen bestellt
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist ich
dachte wir nehmen es heute nur einfach
mal mit rein für die mädels unter euch
weil es sind auch nach wie vor viele
weibliche zuschauer hier auf meinem
kanal unterwegs ist zeigt die statistik
und das macht mich auch sehr stolz daher
genau und ja dann habe ich noch eine
günstige alternative weil ich möchte
dass du das haut serum testet das kostet
22 euro 90 auf der seite muss ich auch
sagen klingt für mich erst mal sehr
teuer weil wir haben eine alternative
gefunden von rossmann für vier euro 50
oder so passt auf nimm einfach mit gäste
das und sache ob du es gut findet und ob
du sagst das ist das geld wert wir haben
uns jetzt mal die spanne reicht von
johanna andy hat dass nämlich alles
getestet und ich bin sehr gespannt gibt
euch mal ausdrücklich schneide ich
gerade noch das video hier super g alex
also ich habe die produkte jetzt mal
angefangen übers wochenende zu testen
und ich dachte es gibt ja so war meine
erste rezensionen dazu ab also das was
man gekauft haben ist für das geld
eigentlich total gut gewesen ich finde
nur wenn man das hier darauf macht das
strafgeld schon direkt also man fühlt
dass irgendwie das ist ein bisschen
spannend sag ich mal so aber jetzt nicht
negativ und das von paypal das habe ich
dann auch noch mal ausprobieren damit
bin ich sogar mehr zufrieden wenn ich
ehrlich bin also auch wenn zeit viel
teurer ist
und das hat mir richtig gut gefallen und
von der konsistenz und wie sich das auf
der haut anfühlt und ich habe von den
sachen halt auch noch andere produkte
getestet dieses reinigungsgel und so und
die sache war nicht auch alle total gut
die griechen halt auch nicht so extrem
am sonntag sehr natürlich was bei diesem
rossmann serie jetzt nicht der fall weil
so das riecht ein bisschen ja künstlich
sage ich mal so aber da ist ja jeder
eigentlich bin müsst ihr natürlich ja
sag ich mal so ich finde beide sachen
auf jeden fall ganz gut ja leute wenn
ihr dieses video seht bin ich schon auf
kreta wir sind mit unserer social media
agentur also agency eine woche auf kreta
machen da richtig coolen urlaub ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen führt zwei
tasten nach oben da ich hoffe es war
nicht zu chaotisch ich habe mein bestes
gegeben und ich muss sagen die influenza
produkte haben überraschend gut
abgeschnitten wir sehen uns nächste
woche gibt's neues video abonniert sehr
sehr gern den kanal haut reichen sollte